I was considered the dancing as the
center of gay life dancing together
that's our spiritual center so to have
something violated that deeply in our
spiritual center is exactly what
happened in orlando florida
a horrible tragedy Atlanta immediately
reminded me of the stone world because
it was a dancing place it was and it was
it a place where people went out that
night to be happy they went out to be
happy and feel good with their friends
think of it to go out to have a good
time and then don't go home again the
night of the riots was like every other
night and two until it got crazy and
then that night changed the world
when this happened in rule and all right
I felt like it was going back to before
stoma because back then there wouldn't
have been 50 people shot at once but
there would be people getting beat up
all over the place that was just so
common back then what gay people share
as something that brings us together
which is love is what's going to hold us
together and keep us going but we'll
keep going because we'll keep dancing
together and nothing's going to stop us
from dancing together